bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est à
l'ifa à berlin avec christophe
christophe qu'il ya un truc qui est
extraordinaire
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer nous
montrer ta petite boule et nous comment
ça fonctionne exactement la petite boule
s'appelle paulo tonique avec photonique
on change de sa manière de vivre la
musique c'est tout mais mouvement pour
pouvoir piloter la musique way est
effectivement tu as raison la première
chose à faire c'est de la démontrer sans
pareil busin pas de musique pas de
mouvement pas de musique d'accord petit
mouvement la musique des mains ouais
je vais jouer sur l'amplitude mon geste
est plus lent que je démarre la musique
jacques et s'arrête pas là
j'accélère musique s'accélère c'est dans
mon corps
mais si je m'arrête la musique s'arrête
tout sur les pilotes
voilà ce que font les politiques avec
plan l'application je peux jouer
uniquement le rythme je peux jouer dans
la mélodie et pourquoi est ce que je
trouve ça c'est tout simplement qu'après
je vais choisir dans une tout un tas de
playlists je vais pouvoir choisir et ma
mélodie et mon rythme donc je vais
pouvoir faire des knicks à une très
grande récré en librairie avec un plein
de musiques différentes mélodies et qui
peut mixer la mairie d'un morceau avec
le rythme de leurs morceaux
ce qui nous amène à plus de 1000 mix
possible d'accord donc ça veut dire que
bien quoi faire quoi faire et après j'ai
même pour les experts on appelle les
vielles combinaison parce que une fois
qu'ils commençaient à jeter sur quelle
musique bella dans la
la modifier pour la modifier j'ai un
truc encore plus magique de ce coup
marek de ce coup et là ma musique a
changé c'est un maquillage aussi lorsque
vendre les classements on peut imaginer
avoir un jongleur qui à faire de la
musique en même temps peut imaginer
plein plein de solutions là il ya un
côté ceneri de quoi graphique est
clairement là quand est-ce que deuxième
chose si je suis danseur et je le prends
sur moi
ouais et ça veut dire que je suis super
mauvais danseurs ont fait venir
d'habitude pour me caler sur la sur la
musique c'est super compliqué là il va
se passer exactement le même
c'est la musique qui va se caler sur
monde j'ai beaucoup de mélanges de
classe on n'applique pas ce que je fais
ça s'arrête toujours la vie facile
c'est génial quoi d'autre comme
application qu'un le guitariste le
guitariste en majuscules mettre le
rythme il va prendre sa guitare
ouais il va jouer la guitare et puis ce
qui va se passer il a sa batterie a pas
de règle qui peut même lui se décaler en
jouant sa guitare exactement dans
toujours bon et ça marche toujours
c'est vraiment plein de choses à faire
pour les enfants pour l'éveil musical
vraiment les applications qui sont
vraiment multiples dont il disait aussi
qu'on peut le plus gay a pour les
personnes ne seront plus au niveau de la
musique pour les dj / humble tonne life
ouais c'est ça c'est nous tous les
nouveaux produits c'est qu'en fait on a
rajouté un plugin à bolton et ça on va
donc sur cette partie là on utilise le
flou tonique pour manipuler note du coup
n'importe quelle musique la cancel qu'on
va apporter à l'intérieur à bolton
couette mais là c'est plus pour les dj
wiwi et dj vont même pouvoir aller
limite exporter la partie avec nick
donner des foules au tonic au public et
va pouvoir interagir avec le clown est
plutôt bluffant
le public va pouvoir faire une partie de
mélo une partie de vos batteries et
l'artiste jaune aurait exactement et la
sarre en met un échange entre le dj et
le public les a grandi et quelque chose
de génial alors se sont petit produit là
il est commercialisé à partir de
maintenant les disponible il est déjà
disponible et déjà sur les tablettes on
est présent en france on est présent sur
la partie allemagne au niveau de la
suède on commence au niveau de la
belgique et la livre a été
génial pour rencontrer d'autres
distributeurs et d'autres italiens et à
c'est un produit qu'on vous trouverez à
quel tarif à 81 81 03 chaque acheteur
très sympa bon je vous mets tout en
commentaire je vous mets le dans la
description parlons de la description je
vous mets le lien pour arriver comment
ce produit qui est vraiment très sympa
cette fois j'ai pensé à toi de jouer
avec ces bleus là c'est vrai que ça il
parlait des cons pour y passer des
heures à faire ça je me dis dans la
description
dites moi ce que vous en pensez si vous
trouvez le produit qu louis oulon aller
faire un tour vous allez voir c'est un
produit qui est très bien tant merci
merci à toi et puis je vous dis à très
bientôt
salut à gâteau